hey boomer let's do it come on man I'm
not posting right now guys I got weed Oh
debride it Singh is sick dude don't it's
multicolored come on blue
don't be addicted cool no listen I'm
this is this is I got to get back to my
[ __ ] TV show I don't have a lot of
time let's rock I got a ready to do this
yeah TV show yeah TV show it's laughs
out of y-y-ya commitment yeah man come
on guys oh yeah I feel you man I got a
this weekend I got a I got 30,000 people
to come see me at a chase arena you know
where they uh the Warriors they put
enough Curry's Steph Curry yet - Zarina
already Ana and that's a team with
another team catch a sellout that arena
it's just me in a stool not even the
playoffs
I feel great on a Thursday okay yeah
yeah I get what the TV show thing yeah
you let's do this you get to your TV
show thirty thousand seconds I have a
private jet in betweens so I'm doing
Chase Arena on Thursday and then I get
on a private jet
fly to Seattle okay I do another arena
and then I get on a private jet hands
well that way you know likes where
there's light paths why you show me the
path lap list the flight pattern I know
you're making your hands all creepy weed
tight like you're knifing them yeah
can we talk about hands yeah so I buy a
cookie I trained karate oh my god so I
buy cookie please tell him I buy a
cookie and I go this is not vegan
because the guy sold me and he said this
is a vegan cookie I know this is not
vegan it's too good to be abused gotta
be butter and Adam Brian goes let me try
sticks his hand like first of all who
grabs a anything like this like it's a
turtle yeah my plucky only has three
fingers let's talk to pinky yeah dr.
pinky grab your la crabbed it broke a
piece off touch the entire cookie the
entire cookie and then shoved all four
fingers in his mouth to the second
knuckle who's this guy and then pulled
it out it was just good I had to clean
all the chocolate on a finger dude well
what I do is I drag and then
wiped it off like that and I go I don't
want to share any finger food items with
you well because I drag my fingers along
the cookie I started from the very edge
of the crust drag along then just I know
just to put my mark on my arms and then
I broke it off I'm not saying that you
like I know the joke is that you're
everyone thinks her old that's what
that's like coming to put a lot of
people I know you're being a dick right
now but the way you ate that cookie is
old old that's like challah
that's fair like someone that's in a
nursing home [ __ ] fingers uh yeah I
did I did I did with my finger I don't
want it now it's it was look you did it
you're guilty your honor
you know you know Meadows ten minutes
tell me that show how you did it sure I
did
I just show my you did I'm gonna go
along here I'll reenact it Brendan this
is there's no way this is vegan I'm
gonna try yeah maybe you'll try it let
Brian try a piece get your old buddy
that's exactly how he did it right but
he was talking to me as if no one knows
he cramped all his finger to his [ __ ]
mouth I was like he's telling me what
you know you know I really like what you
Bubble Boy did you just cram all your
[ __ ] fingers in your mouth no [ __ ]
given either was there Brian I'm sorry
it's just I still trying
he was the last one my fingers have my
whistle are very clear move everything
clean not what's yours go [ __ ] yourself
it's yours but also when the show's done
I'll try it
joke Oh Congrats on all your success
thank you so much it's kind of nuts it's
crazy and I love you thanks to you guys
well we do better we take credit for it
seriously you and I suppose juice
sneaker shopping bro I you know what's
funny is this is what annoys me the most
okay and it no no disrespect to anyone
that's that's in the shoe game right now
but but I've been a sneaker head since
Jump Street right and when I mean Jump
Street I mean the actual [ __ ] show
Jump Street yeah man and like uh it's so
funny that these little shits come to my
show right it'll be like sixteen
seventeen and light oh it's so cool
Joker this you hit I don't like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
yeah did you not see you been doing I
think I'm gonna make a video and show
what I wore like my first special my
first I wearing your first special uh
Olympic ones and then my Tonight Show
you know other V huh
I'm sorry go get us coffee I wear blunt
I found Jordan Olympic ones go ahead and
then uh The Tonight Show I wore patent
leather everyone oh damn
no that's what I wore on my first puzzle
game angry all the way over to the left
the original EOG right there yeah it was
super fast but I fresh that's what I
wore right so sick so sick I still got
him in a box you know what's interesting
now is like the shoe game is so did when
I was a kid we would like any Jordans
the five sixes we drew up at like Foot
Locker and we out you have to wait in
line to three hours really we had a good
chance of giving them yeah now now
because you know people are getting
robbed and shot and arms taking off as
Linda throws for Jordan's so now what
they do is it's only on the app so it's
nothing's in person alright so but you I
gotta wake up at 7:00 a.m. at 36 years
old I wake up at 7 a.m. on a Saturday
when I'm on the road yeah I get on the
app and you got a just submit to see if
you're in the is that a new thing battle
but here's a prompt B here's the problem
so sinker has like me and Joe we're not
getting it
these box
then these companies are because they
have these all this like yeah that just
suck it all up because they're flipping
them why I had a friend who's uh you
know he ran with a rough crowd he he
would sell some stuff for the Hells
Angels and he goes I see him and he goes
I don't do I don't do it anymore man
you need some easy so what he is yeah I
make the profit off that's more than
anything I can do in the drug business
here so I just have connect to the Yi's
on how he's getting them just and I get
the surplus and I just just shows that
he was my flip it for way faster how
much does he make on Yeezys for example
thousand depend on which ones now
there's a lot out there but certain
shoes like specially dunks dunks are
like right now sb dunks are like the hot
what are dunks did you see the shoes
times why do you act like this why do
you ruin every conversation you just
ruin every clothes role why you're like
my dad be cool
the second ones in the Valentine sense
knows our dough Papa just got those
that's cool I swear you're so annoying
why I'm sure dope those are sick by the
way those are all I got I gotta hook you
up with my gut you're and uh el pasado
that's in San Antonio but boy Jake does
custom shoes for LeBron Beckham
everybody that's he brought me custom
custom supreme ones low tops show him
those chin Brian go get us something
[ __ ] no I want to be part of this oh
I love some fresh kicks you know what I
hate the most is like this would be such
a great conversation yeah you're ruining
well I'm not doing anything else you're
ruining old I'm listening
you're being very old no I'm not I'm
saying it's like fresh and grow dope
those are sick so he makes them for Nike
he make hits the all the the other the
materials are from where Nike gets
theirs oh really
office and just refurbished is the whole
thing does its own style oh good I'm
really nervous like a really detail how
do they get that dope that dope
you're you're annoying well why why get
back on set bro I'm literally just
sitting here as an actor as a working
actor then time offer you how much say
line again how long does it take you to
remember your three lines in that show
no first of all like three that's a [ __ ]
anything mistakes I'm the star and also
I have a photographic memory yeah and no
one believed that that's why we're not
completely July it
I remember the internet shut down you
know I you know
you know I realize that when you're on a
set of course we all know it's the death
of fun you need a lot of ways because
you're waiting and you do the same thing
over and over again and the only thing
you want to do on a TV show room is you
better have people you can be silly with
because if you don't if you I don't know
how people can like Joaquin Phoenix how
could they can just be actors hold that
that preparation yeah yeah he wouldn't
talk to anybody but director yeah like
III know but for three months I would go
but be go crazy since they won an Oscar
yeah that's all he cares about that's
right there's a difference there's a
difference between actors like you and I
can't act and have fun yeah and then
there's actors who become whatever it is
that's on that page and those people I
say are clinically insane right and
they're functional schizophrenic oh and
I'm not trying to be funny or anything
like that but you can't sit here and act
like I want to hang out with Johnny Depp
you can't well how about that you can't
well I don't want to hang out with a
pirate because he will be a pirate
pirate what six [ __ ] months he will
be a pirate like I go to Foot Locker and
he's like let me do you one better
so Daniel de Loup yeah let me do you one
better
okay lowest remember that movie my left
foot yes yeah okay so it's about a
painter Chris Christie oh he's a painter
bring it up and he could only use his
left foot he had cerebral palsy all
right Doug removed and him you know that
now now take a look at him as the actor
in this first second I just wanted
because as the actor yeah now now he
basically was a simple act no no he had
cerebral palsy but he was normal and all
he could do is paint he could paint with
his
yeah now now up to the parable remember
this movie now apparently and he wasn't
even a well-known actor as it went
apparently and he won an Oscar for it
the [ __ ] guy had well he's booked it
they got the guy had yes to the guy look
at him the guy had people changing him
and helping him take a [ __ ] and wipe his
ass oh he went full on and he did that
for I don't know how long it took to do
the movie but he did it the whole time
now look at him nah man that movie's
sick but well that's why he's the best I
know yeah he's willing to do things that
others won't do yeah I'm not interested
go ahead III got that character when
they say cut and we like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
man
I can't do anything I'm done correct I'm
done currently my other foot or or how
about Jim Carrey for the grit oh you
were 12 hours I was in had to give that
3 a.m.
did you sign on MADtv and I was going
crazy not month two months and my only
did it for like I would do it for a week
at a time and you get there 5:00 in the
morning and they paint your face and put
plastic you go crazy they say he had a
crazy coach yeah who talked him into
going somewhere else because they would
just sit there it's so uncomfortable
it's so uncomfortable it's so crazy that
you just said that did you see the post
of him on Instagram no I just saw it
yesterday where they asked him about the
Grinch how kids come up to him like like
this is an old interview yeah and
they're asking him how he got into the
character uh and he morphed his face
with no make up into the bro but if you
pull it up and I'm not even joking
that was him right there I saw it right
no no that that's it that's it that's it
watch this it's unbelievable another
parent says you know who it is that's
the Grinch and I go oh [ __ ] that's all
my must find a wave to stop Christmas
from Gabby you know pan-roast god dude
was that not the let me I didn't let me
see that yeah watch it again that's
without makeup he doesn't need makers
you know who look at this that's the
Grinch and I go I must find a way to
stop Christmas from gambling
no bro I'm taking the guy happy
yeah that's an athlete that's an alien
he's that's a nail he is from another
planet and that's why he's Jim Carrey is
one the greatest of all things the
greatest of all I'm gonna take my son as
she saw it the hedgehog tomorrow
that's the movies doing oh is that
whatever Sony yeah god bad guide solid
he's amazing that's who that is yeah
I've even recognized I like the hats
unbelievable dude the greatest of all
time I'm sorry man
he's great me myself and Irene one of my
favorite I think he's astonishing like
my friend my friend Joe Truman Show Me
Myself & Irene is the most underrated
movie that he ever did that's where he
played three people yeah and crushed him
evil guy - it didn't do well but Ben
Stiller wrote it shut up good Jim Carrey
was in it is supposed to be super dark
yeah so the original take of cable guy
was dark he would like kill people do
super dark stuff yes and the studio's
like uh uh we haven't it so that to
change it and that's when like Stiller
and uh
Carey like other thing that's in what we
were doing man yeah I love that movies I
love that [ __ ] on it but I know I
know somebody who to date him and I also
know somebody worked with him for a long
time and yeah and they always talked
about how he he he was always he's kind
of bipolar you always know they're
probably on the set waiting for you well
I was dying the guy the person I know is
me and but he you as a comic and stuff
remember he was like you know what I'm
really good at doing impressions not
doing that anymore as a comic he would
destroy getting standing ovations not
gonna do that anymore I'm gonna try
something different it was always when
he apparently with in living color
always always [ __ ] around with
different characters like he never
stopped well you know at the comedy
store he would go on he was one of the
only guys would go on and he'd do
something new every single night and a
lot of times he ate dick
yeah and so nights he came up with
something but you just go on and do new
[ __ ] everything a night this was so
funny remember him oh my so he was to
Milo so [ __ ] so funny oh my god hire
Marshall bill that's great do you
remember to stand up I remember when you
used to do a t-rex
personation it's just I would die and
Clint Eastwood cleany ah so amazing man
it's so amazing night paints are just
like talking [ __ ] about drunk Chris
Farley ever do stand-up no he saw him in
another thing he [ __ ] makes me laugh
Tim Meadows was saying he's just been on
Saturday Night Live where they come into
a crime scene as two detectives and and
they look at it mr. [ __ ] there's a
dead body and Chris Farley go [ __ ] all
right play a pastime let me suck your
[ __ ] because I think I know what
happened here everything here was
hilarious my favorite story about Chris
is like everyone else is fighting to get
there uh whatever they wrote to Lorne
Michaels yeah I think Chris would walk
in with nothing but then get all the
sketches although of course just walk in
with nothing never had anything but
everyone's fighting Lorne please look at
this I think Chris just walked in late
and I'm like yeah let's give it to him
shared an office with Chris Rock Sandler
and say yeah so all of them would stay
up all night writing and come and just
[ __ ] around like see in the morning do
you see my David Letterman where that
one thing he did was like my dad told me
don't make a fool of yourself don't make
a fool and he goes I went to this fat
farm and I was dancing he starts dead I
was dying he goes we are the king come
on he's the [ __ ] game you know it was
it was do you remember this yes he just
starts going crazy because apparently
he'd be really nervous backstage and you
know and then he will out and just
destroy
isn't that crazy with so in that town it
has like anxiety issues or or you know
the nervous like what do you never said
that's why I David let him and stop
doing Stan hey did the nerves of it cuz
really it was every night hey did do it
wasn't no but but you know they would
not be whitey baseball time what happen
you don't have to do that David
yeah why I have my reasons why I have my
reasons I got a either what oh I don't
like he passed on you know I I did a
show I did send about a show
don't think he's funny was never a comic
you know he's gonna be this large guild
host I'm gonna be in host good watch
this little will the greatest not not
not close to he's just there for a long
time not close to the Conan O'Brien oh
look what's that guy got that got to go
smart snarky snarky good you know you do
it long enough you're gonna be okay
but now I got nothing for David he
wasn't a good morning how about that
wasn't that's a fact he was a he was a
weather man yeah and then he became a
comic I tried to be kind of a writer
well you know why he stopped doing
comedy Jay Leno he saw Jay Leno's like
how good he was and he was like a
wordsmith and his grind names it go I'm
not I'm not gonna do that like I can't
compete with that
how the hell do you get the show then
and that crazy how do you live in a time
right place right time good you know
what that good yeah
not bad probably pretty smart hard work
who's definitely good he was really good
oh yeah I loved watching
he caught a sight guys he was I remember
when he became famous and and I remember
when he started and why people liked it
it was a it was a time yeah when somehow
that fit in he was so it was like
jadianna what do you think Jay Leno's
funny for those hosts like that's what
you know but I like but do you think
Carson's funny Carson was very good at
what he did he was good so good was so
of course some wood dude Carson's timing
was was so available yeah I think Kyle I
think Conan's the wall I love Kimmel - I
like Kimmel viana I love camels out
strike Fallon sounds good
I like Kimmel I like and I like her own
okay now what are they - the big boy
James Gordon is great - don't know I
don't know at the same time they do like
the car karaoke hairdo skits mmm I love
it he's killing it watching those shows
though no one's watched many more like
you're gonna get more eyeballs on this
yeah I went on 100% Allen or so it's not
the same like I I don't want to no hate
but burning your material on those shows
aren't like what they used to did you
ever do I did this Tonight Show and I'm
telling you right now man I did it with
Jay Leno and what year man this is 15
years ago so 2004
and I got a I killed it and I didn't
know how many people watched it because
I was still working at Nordstrom Rack I
was a shoe salesman so they would you
know you bring the right foot to me and
I go get your left foot in the back yeah
and and yeah that one and I'm wearing a
patent leather Air Force Ones and uh and
every single customer was like dude you
were so funny on this Tonight Show
that's no lie that's so and then I got a
commercial deal from this set I got a
commercial deal from this set I got I
went on this major tour for a cell phone
company they were paying me like three
thousand a gig I mean all from this set
to change my life I was working at
Nordstrom Rack and borders books at this
time I was broke us and I was I was able
to quit my job
Wow job that one sentence of that
Saturday night 4-minute said I did
Letterman in 1999 look at those airports
a guy named game cook as part of a new
Cano allocated jeans those yeah well you
were you nervous for the no not in the
bag oh you don't want to cry backstage
too because the Letterman passed on this
set he we sent it to him twice and he
passed he said it was a usual your
physical he hated this yeah he said I
was too physical or whoever was the
Booker and then Ross and Bob saw me do
this set at new faces at Just for Laughs
and they say save that set we want to
put you on the best night so we're gonna
find like the best landing Morissette
and Joaquin Phoenix
yeah and that was and I got to stand I
remember I remember you back then
because we knew each other and you know
you were killing back then like you
would get up on at the Laugh Factory and
destroy rooms so it's like yeah and then
bladder man was like well what comes not
a lot of talks on this book a lot of
times it's not yeah it's not it's about
I don't have a guy yeah they have a guy
but also a lot of times it is there was
a thing yeah well he did I that's what
they said you say this is Jay he didn't
like I know the Booker's I know news
book is pretty well and they're awesome
but they were very very aware of what he
liked very very and to get a style they
were tuned so they were very worried if
involved that let's go to Jay Leno
no they were good they did a great job
job
before we go on about Brian's past and
you know his issue with David Letterman
this is also a guy who doesn't think
Brad Pitt's berrytown Oh see I never
said that and Tom hey never said that
you do that I never said they're not did
he say that I said they don't do
anything I've never gone to a movie for
those guys they're other actors I like
you said you went you never went to a
movie with Tom Hanks no never on Hanks
well almost never made you want to buy a
ticket Tom Hanks is awesome but that's
not why I would go to the movie
necessarily for whatever reason it's
like people like the police and the cars
the great bands never never really spoke
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt is a movie star
right he's a movie star it's just it's
just a different thing and III think
he's awesome in certain I loved him and
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I loved
him in heaven and in seven he was great
made him a star I loved him I know a
club he was awesome so certain roles
he's throwing awesome you know anything
with his shirt off yes yeah he was great
and Thummim noise I'm not saying that
he's a success not an accident it's just
I'm what I'm saying is that there are
other actors as far as just acting who
can who become characters what do you
say about him though what do you say
about red Nick I don't go Ryan Brian
shut the [ __ ] up there sorry what do you
it's okay sorry what do you what did
Brian say about Brad he essentially said
that he never went to a movie
specifically because those men were in
the film and then he started to double
down and said you know what I don't
think he's that good yeah did you dance
what you said you're not that good you
have to face that man that's exactly
just what an awesome well yeah you don't
say something like that right now well
what I say that after I saw Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood you took it back yeah
sorry take it back right now
I'm sorry that I said he's sorry is not
that he's not that good he's a [ __ ]
movie star yeah and he has magic yeah
charisma oh you change all but and I'm
telling him and checks all boxes I'm
telling you man whatever you know what I
thought was lost him about once upon a
time in Hollywood is his ability to be
great in silence like his timing is
impeccable
of course I just Pat in the past there
are other people that I I think are
better yeah that fight scene between him
a Bruce Lee I love the rose all up in
arms
it's overrated yeah but that's but okay
this is this is my take on that movie my
take on that movie is there's a lot of
people in this industry that have
stories yes there's a lot of behind the
scenes yes and they are elaborated and
embellished stories this is once upon a
time I lived next to Sharon Tate yeah
yeah and you don't believe it I don't
know what the killers a couple like yeah
it's right [ __ ] Hollywood stories
one spot yeah I was on the set with
Bruce Lee and you know I don't believe
it man
the [ __ ] was at the crash came
up beat the [ __ ] out of him yeah yeah
and there's other actors like what yeah
and that's why that was my take on that
that was like I don't know why people up
in arms about it I thought it was I love
that that was the Chuck Zito story who
was in Hell's Angels who knocked out
Sean Claude Van Damme and when I was
doing Oz Chuck was on the show so all of
us has actors back tell us the story
about when you knocked out jean-claude
Van Damme and there would be a story was
that it was a Hollywood story yeah now I
don't just don't say hi and I don't know
what I believe the Chuck Zito will punch
you in the face that data but he's very
resonant Hells Angels you know how many
stories I've heard from Jamie Masada
about what's happened upstairs at the
Laugh Factory on some big names that I
would never ever say publicly really
yeah yes Brown imagine the movie that I
could make just off of those stories
yeah you know what I'm talking about
you've heard you you've never have you
ever talked to Jamie oh yeah yeah
exactly
it's it's not good no and I and I've
heard some bad ones and the funny being
is one of they're also like and there's
other there's other old-school comics
that back it like yup oh yeah and you're
just like what because you know what
comics are and should be misfits and
let's be honest let's be honest all of
us you you and me everybody we know but
at the end of the day are trying to
control their miss Fitness yeah there
there miss Fitness NISS yes you feel
like you miss fit Joe I feel like what
it is is uh we've been blessed with such
an amazing job and our job is to just be
her cell
then I don't think we can ever like take
real responsibility you can't yeah I
don't like one thing I that really
annoys me is when someone goes guy can't
she be serious and I'm like no no I
can't come ake millions of dollars
I make million this week millions of
dollars I don't need to be depressed and
in my [ __ ] ears right now and I've
always loved you for that yeah I've
always loved that you cuz lot comics
aren't this way what I love about you
from day [ __ ] one is you celebrate
other people's success oh wait you're
always positive yes and you're always
[ __ ] hilarious and as I get at 50
[ __ ] three and I'm old and I really
say this you know what my new goal is
dead serious shut up I'm not shutting
the [ __ ] up please
shot in the [ __ ] up but I'm not taking
myself seriously yeah no more at all no
I don't want at all d3 no dude it starts
to you know you really need fish oil for
those joints right but your joint no
that wasn't a point that what you're
getting here
no I opened myself up and now you guys
have been a dick about my eight I know
you gave me a really nice compliment
about how yeah then he went right to
your knees and how how you don't have
time the time is limited now cuz you're
you're on the other side now the back
you're on the other side yeah you're
having down the hill and then come back
now you know what else to respect a lot
of time climbing up that hill but now
you're [ __ ] your role in my own time
so yes I'm gonna have I'm gonna have my
day your day bro you're going back on
this set yeah but I'm not sound like
30,000 tickets on my villa no you're not
well actually that's just the two shows
in San Francisco if you add up the whole
weekend it's close to what we figure out
you okay
60,000 again all right Joe I'm trying to
sell it the West Palm Beach improv this
weekend I'll be there for Valentine's
Day Friday Saturday Sunday I'm [ __ ]
quitting stand up
joke joke joke but the thing is about
Jodi so I was I was at the store where
some I was son you'll be top five comics
points on tickets that's crazy
for shine for sure 100% you know I was
so nervous to push cuz you warm on sale
like literally I was never
I was just like I don't want to do this
I was so comfortable with the improv
Xand and then and and my team was like
let's just try the let's try the form
and I had this bucket list I put out
last year
it said form Staples the dark
constitutional hall where Eddie Murphy
shot delirious Radio City Music Hall and
I said the Sydney Opera House and I said
I want to do it before 2020 so we put
them all on sale and they all sold out
in minutes oh my god it [ __ ] is like
on can you do a commercial for my West
Palm Beach I always promote you Brian it
was crazy
I always push you and I think I think
every comic should celebrate other
comics like you said I agree why
wouldn't you when your special came out
I [ __ ] loved it I pushed it I
promoted it thank and this is before I
was even doing this show by the way I
think you know what I mean I love you
yeah the best man I was come on kolchin
dude I can't believe this though 60,000
tickets yeah that one was in the round
in Hawaii I did two of those that was
20,000 somebody does the that sure is
that your nephew there that's my son
oh that's right I love how many just the
form hold the form is 13,000 no comps by
the way it was so funny all right back
to back all right Joe 26 okay 26 in
change cups what are you doing with your
money so funny they're like on your
artist holds Joe do you want to release
something I was like I don't have that
many friends go ahead and sell Joe and
get Brett well we'll get Brian in we'll
get Brian a ticket no doc don't do that
was crazy that's NJPAC I'd see that and
I did that three times what I did two on
the same night look at that
and now Bryan Callen your headliner you
guys now Bryan how many times have I
asked you to come to my show
to be honest I've asked you so many
times to come to my show
you mean that you're to come on my show
to go to go up and perform I've asked
you and I've asked Bret I've asked you
come I'll come once
let me come to a tight out I don't give
a [ __ ] that's not what I want from you
okay you just you just I want to keep
them there I want to contain them yeah
because you leave it all the whole goal
yeah man the whole goal is to keep them
in there for a certain amount of time
give them a [ __ ] show yeah so you
would go in there three like salt and
pepper like little three four minutes
you know whatever your that's know so
it's something do I fly up myself and
the night don't fly you I got a private
jet you got like ah you're like ten open
seats but like but uh no generally if I
reach in huh
and what would I do you want me to do
and you got just yeah be them zebra
maybe James this is so good
[Music]
just got real I feel like crying yeah
song makes me want to cry just watching
that that's things so dope I know I joke
around man but I pinch myself every day
some money let's go spend your money
what's good now what are you now now
everything's free you know hashtags look
but have you what have you done for
yourself what indulgence have you given
yourself because you're always the same
well I don't really tell people what I
do with it we're just really nice
clothes and [ __ ] gems jewelry he knows
his watch Brian let me see your watch
you don't want to see it's a gold rush
man it's what do you have over there
this is Submariner so mine's like two of
those yeah dude you've got to stop your
bitching 87 lucky good yeah the gold is
the weight is less ominous and you're
doing it in a subtle shitty way dude I'm
just doing it for comedy let's talk
watches and I'm not being real like no I
don't mean it but yeah it is
it's just it's a cool dude it's just
this guy dweller for solid gold ok man
see let me let me touch it it's heavy it
is really heavy all right all right Joe
cuz even like you know that little hand
that I think it's called the second hand
yeah it's cool it's ok ok you don't know
how to touch it you grab it like a
[ __ ] cookie you grab you like the
cookie you're putting in your mouth no
[ __ ] mouth you hold the face all
right let me hold the face don't be a
dick man you know what I do is I get
your Joe but I would do if I saw at the
forum
I would buy a watch to celebrate that by
a Daytona you guys you love your watches
yeah watches and I had like a lot and I
wouldn't wear this had a lot of heavy
you know I bought I bought this one find
the kid 3d you went number one on it
that's beautiful but yeah I want that
one oh yeah I love that one oh that
looks terrible on Brian this is not
before you let me see how are you you
want to go acting her
I could hell it's a great watch I help
you with your dish you have a bunch of
them let's get you a lot
well I only do Rolex that's my favorite
that's John my son they're all for him
yeah heavy yeah well it's the heaviest
and biggest one from rolling oh yeah I
dude okay you don't even know what
you're doing stop stop you're [ __ ]
making me nervous stop aah Oh give it to
all right it knows how to handle [ __ ]
literally just touching it I gotta lick
my fingers Golf is good really heavy
gold tastes [ __ ] good ah give it to
can you give it to I don't know how to
do rape ape over here I don't scratch it
sorry to get my finger ma on it
I just got spit on my hand from his
fingertip let me smell that golf hey
dude I'm just joking by the way you know
that right
we're dead serious thanks Joe well you
know what that's my camera which one's
my that was the only way have you had
worked on in your face cuz you look
tight no no it's that's asian so like
what do you have Asian jeans yeah you
don't get that many lines across the
forehead right so yours is like like a
tree like when you cut a tree if you
count I say to the tree there's like
seven rings like your pieces are eating
every ring is 10 years yeah so that's
like I say it's more like a packet of
baked goods have a pack of bacon yeah
yeah say that about my face man I'm
wearing makeup so the the 11th okay so
you know when you cut a tree yes did you
see the Rings I hate this plant account
you can't count how old the tree is and
buy the Rings I know you said you like
when you like like raise your eyebrows
no just raise your eyebrow no that's a
black surprise real quick like look up
look up Wow yeah
each line is like seven years no it's
not how many did you count 10 no don't
what is 7 times 6 I'm bad at math it's
like 79 or 4240 there's the other thing
so then that's wrong yeah yeah that's
wrong
it wants peace
one more time fine I'm gonna do it again
but don't I want I won't
nope you know me I'm not shaky come on
oh you forgot the line in the middle of
his eyebrows hey there's no so 7 times 8
is 56
am i right your your head is like dog
ears each line is like seven years can't
say my face is a tree and like dog ears
you can't say that there's eight lines
across your head
oh there's times that by seven seven
times eight is what it if I get my times
eight is what bright seven times eight
56 58 how old are you I'm 53 boom Bryce
ik Brian Brian same bag in his lids done
though yeah yeah we talked about I can't
see well I've aged that's the difference
between 49 and 53 that lat eyelids you
can't see my eyes yeah it's like he has
a visor over both eyes now and it's from
years of boxing sports well it's far
still [ __ ] by the way [ __ ] I [ __ ] well
yeah well who knows but here's my
question you still [ __ ] I was gonna tell
you no I don't know now you're a prude
look at you I don't want to talk about
that with you you just smile you just
swallowed with your mouth open you went
I'm sure I'm sure
hey hey I'm sure no girls like the outer
cells 60,000 tickets in two days let me
ask you a question don't don't [ __ ]
betray with a swallow trying to be yeah
hey bro what you're already relaxed your
[ __ ] you have this makes you hungry like
Letterman just before he's about to be
hey take it easy
look at me playing with your watch I
just want you to ask that question while
holding they know you're trying to
deflect oh hey Joe your fourth friends
yeah oh you know I want you to do
chalking bring up bring up Joe's Sam
Adams commercial there may be classes
that made me cry
can I make you cry you know that made
that almost made us you do really we
started
on this I had to get it together that's
nice my mom it was nice Joe is you did
it for your mom who actually was super
considerate and enjoyed it and then when
I did for Brian he he didn't care no I
did I did care actually all the jokes I
don't want to work this is my dream come
true oh that's the view from my house
comic yo yo yo de have you seen this jo
koy stand-up comedian and I'm here to
toast my mother how you gonna make me
cry
without her none of this would have
happened now is that your house yeah
freak pepe coolness be cool we [ __ ]
cool dude that's my pool suppose it's a
music notice story that makes me yeah
you [ __ ] thank me but grateful [ __ ] my
mom sacrificed everything to make me the
opportunity to live my dream and this
toast was the best opportunity for me to
say thank you when I get your hazelnuts
my eyes out of my [ __ ] face I know
this is my favorite commercial damn I'm
not kidding are you serious right I got
it sweet ours is old and not bad family
what I said I want to be a comic her
head was like what are you crazy
that's your pool I know it looks like a
hotel is that a four-season feeling yeah
this is a great commercial know we live
in a country where dreams are possible
and it can't happen just give me some
time since day one I wanted to make sure
that the world could laugh and when I
tell your story on stage it's something
that I'm very proud of for years I was
like how am I gonna talk about my mom I
didn't want to go up on stage and just
be like oh I'm Filipino and Filipinos do
this and I take the shades off you're
gonna be like oh my mom does the same
[ __ ] I mean you do be great and then
probably you wanted me to be a lawyer
well we digress now I see being a
comedian my goodness
I mean you're 1000% secure Sam Adams
it's grassroots its family what I take
from that is the same thing that
for my mom and that's why Sam Adams is
the best beer for this toast the reason
why I brought here today is I wanted to
toast you this is hard harder than I
thought when you came to this country
was to give the kids an opportunity that
you knew that you would never have
everywhere I go people will be yelling
your name and they grab their hand and I
know it's because of you so I also
wanted the moment
I'm so proud of you you see you started
this you're the reason why I've been
able to do this thank you for everything
you sacrificed so this is for you but I
love you dude
I can't all right you doing hard without
dude I can't even take a close-up slow
down lady you want some more nobody
could have put that to [ __ ] you oh is
that the purest form of love between a
son and a mother though I can't believe
made that for you I can't take that
commercial now you just made me cry
everybody's crying now yeah just life
are the same Adam guys send in her
office all of them good music everything
I'm the mastermind in Brian's whatever
ours is great but I look so whole I mean
I I'm a tree - I thought it was great I
loved it but I can't watch that either
that makes me emotional but do I show it
on the thing we don't do that enough we
never you and I never do that you and I
never do that ever were you taking the
time to just like yeah thank somebody or
if you want me to cry though but you
know if you want me to cry if I if I've
talked about my brother my dad my mom
yeah it's dude yeah that did that was
hard says like especially because my mom
did not want me to be a comic for so
long she just didn't get it
idiot am i right all right but it's like
she's an immigrant mom she comes from a
very hard place but that's how it's work
she wants yeah yeah but we're talking
about someone that came from the food
so it's even harder where nobody from
and her whole thing was like I'm gonna
have kids but I don't want my kid to be
in the position where I was when I was
his age that's not why I came to America
so for a hint for me to choose something
that you know to hers just like today
it's insane what are you doing and then
like I remember my son was uh when when
I just had my son he was like eight
months old and she took all this money
and gave it to me she was by a car
you said needs to be in a nice car and
she started crying and I was just like
oh she has I'm working at Nordstrom Rack
chasing my dream to be a [ __ ]
comedian you know I mean and I'm just
like godlike but I didn't want to like
tell her I'm gonna you know I didn't
want to say I'm gonna quit okay mom
you're right like I just give me some
time it's gonna happen yeah that's
incredible that's it's incredible
understood I said you know what's
interesting now is like let's say your
son wants to be a comic it's just it's
obviously you have a different
perspective because you are such a
successful comic but it's just like even
if he wants to be a comic the chance of
making it's not good no especially
growing up Wednesday was I went oh boy
how was I when you told me you wanted to
be a comic yeah Brendon was like I want
to be a comic and I was like this he
does your joke about but I was like oh
like my voice got high well yeah oh you
want it that's what you want you know
it's like because yeah Tommy Elvin tells
the story about how when my first set in
the belly room how he sit next to you
and you're like man he's so brave but it
I mean this is it you know it's right
it's to take him at least 15 years look
I couldn't help but worry I know I know
I mean I'm just kidding I was just I
just know the business I know I know but
that's what I'm saying like I was like
in a micro rapport yesterday because he
had this interview my figure was on
unbox or something with a tie Lika leave
I think it says his name but rap was
talking about how when he was a kid in
New York how he would go to these all
black neighborhoods even be on this bike
it was like the hood like Brownsville
and they would call a white Mike and he
was the only white kid but like you just
learned like that street code and that's
how you got was able to talk [ __ ] and
that's just that's what make makes Mike
rapport Mike Rappaport right he's an
amazing dude
and I see the interview and I take
someone I love the interview a lot of
stuff I didn't know about you I said
doesn't it bother you your kids will
never experience that I know where you
live you know where I live our kids are
never gonna experience it like the like
Annamma same gang membership I'm talking
like that street code we're like I'd be
on my bike you know we'd go to this
neighborhood and play pick-up ball here
something like that kids aren't doing
them no they're not you're right I leave
the house we have Mart we have the hoop
there we have the pool you know video
games I would say they'll did the way to
get out of that yeah that maybe is too
just like knowing I would try to do with
my kids is to get them to be into
something and then when you try to get
really good at anything no that's gonna
combat be life god I'll talk to my
people yeah like street lights were on
and like you'd be a little dicey cuz I'd
be going through this neighborhood or me
my brother you know would beat these
guys in basketball and you know that
they didn't like that and it's just like
this isn't part of living in LA though
like this was this white til my girl I
went this is why we're not going to I
said this why I consider moving back to
Venice because you can get it in Venice
a little bit you got to watch your P's
and Q's in Venice yeah you go down a bit
Kenny we go the boardwalk on a Saturday
or certain areas in Venice you gotta
watch your P's and Q's yeah [ __ ] you I
get it palisade you're not getting it
yeah yeah I there's a sense of danger
which I don't want as a father
yeah yeah so I kind of do want you know
Lisa mixed up with different people
right like a you get it coming into
contact one things about New York City
is that you can't help but to be next to
a homeless guy next to a dude has no
money who has a lot of money you're
around people are different right it's
in LA though too but on the pal side you
have to go to and you are walking down
the street in New York right you smell
it you actually are touching it you're
yeah they're having to contend with it
yeah but maybe in Denver you know grown
up in Denver it was like who I dealt
with everyone yeah Romilly black
neighborhood ride our bikes everywhere
weren't sports and Young's were the way
you you know you stood out from people's
like you know yeah I was talking to I
forgot who I was talking to but I was
just like I remember I was on the road
and I was getting an uber for my son so
he can go to his friend's house and I
was just like bro when I was his age if
I went to my friend's house it was
either walk or ride my by
yes I didn't call my mom and arrange a
ride yeah you know what I mean and that
was a very big decision I remember my
friend me like yo get over here and I'm
like I see in five minutes yeah yes sir
and I would ride my bike through the
ring I appreciated it more yeah I'm
saying like it was a big deal to get to
my friends now they're just you know I
don't know what you do I don't know you
do I think that there are new challenges
for kids and are digitally yeah I mean I
think every generation is gonna have
their own set of issues to negotiate
navigate and that maybe is no longer
relevant but there will be something
else that but it's all about your
character also back like oh like you
know the back then we didn't we weren't
aware of all the dangers like we did the
kidnappings and the rapings and people
doing the stuff to kids and now you're
very aware of it though you know now
there's helicopter parents yeah so
Jonathan Hyde said that that's like that
is your chances of a child being
abducted are literally so small but we
are all terrified of X it's the
unimaginable right and so it it was I
guess there were some high-profile cases
no cartons had kids on them and it just
changed how everybody parented their
kids everybody everybody well yeah I'd
rather yeah II don't know how they used
to be you were allowed to let an
eight-year-old nine-year-old go to the
park alone you are that you are I would
not allow the time when people get
arrested I would never but you know what
here's the other thing I would plant
tenants until midnight yeah dude we will
Bolton I can wait in the park everybody
there's nothing I can name the part of
my childhood Park it sprinkle recreation
yeah mine's Utah part in that crazy my
son does not have a porch not play
tennis and basketball all night summer
we would go until [ __ ] like 1:00 a.m.
and we just play with the lights I'll
drink like coca-cola and we straight man
we would heroin thing we were doing
heroin knows what you try not one up a
stack which ones my camera man I don't
know here's the other heroin hold will
you guys let's see these do heroin oh
[ __ ] don't challenge the kids to do it
that's not kids oh [ __ ] don't lie wrong
kid no no don't say kids heroin
heroine play some basketball get a
little suck nah man damn it talk you're
trying to ruin our brand fighter the kid
heavily endorses this message diksa go
far you go find your Park
watch how I stop this hey you [ __ ] bro
stop them in this fat man you can't you
can't even swallow right now I asked you
a question I asked you a question I'm
gonna ask you again do you [ __ ] you
can't even answer it man you might be a
phony sixty thousand tickets my ass
are you dip no no no that's real though
you should have seen that deposit I made
today and if you want to challenge me on
a bet no I'll pull it out I brought my
back man no just in case I don't know
hold for all it you want to go wallet
for wallet Oh since you were bragging
about that goddamn TV set you gotta get
to know but that's it we were getting
copy Brent were you right next to me
Brendan when he said that yeah you did
it goes through I gotta hurry let's get
this pot I got to get to the TV set if
you I like pretty much lapped hard
because awesome doesn't want to do it
bro you want to settle the bet wallet
for wall all right that's so gauche now
I'm just saying I have a Noblet full of
money you can challenge that or you can
go with the deposit slips I did Sam
triple everyone last night and I got
[ __ ] cash on me to take pride yeah
but I have a lot I'm awesome
Oh about kids to be when when when I
left there's no cell phones so in my
mind my parents think they're whatever
yeah go to the park he's good you're
going the part just make sure you at the
park we'd be at the party then come back
now there's cell phones
tracking them I I think we're better
half taking a chance on our kids I think
we're better off taking a chance on
letting your kids do stuff on their own
and taking that chance at the end of the
day that's the irony of it all
you're better off you might be doing
more harm ironically by cloister italic
opt ring and let them play on their own
and navigate their own lands I think
there's a devastating helicoptering and
then just being like present kids aren't
allowed to play alone and then settle
their own problems either what happens
is kids going on authority figure now
because there's always somebody watching
and supervising playtime and Jonathan
hydroids writes about this it's a
problem because it used to be kids
[ __ ] around one kid got bullied yeah
and guess what figured it out
certain schools for sure yeah but now
it's like it's all being supervised it's
really weird and it's interesting to see
where we're headed
yeah yeah okay here's here's my problem
with that is uh is there a difference
like now that this whole bully thing and
then there's people supervising I still
feel like the kids are still individuals
because my son ain't part of this whole
conversation right now what do you mean
whatever just like this whole like this
movement this this kid movement and
anti-bullying that everyone's
supervising Buba blood my son is not
even in like one I don't even talk to
him about that [ __ ] and he's got his own
opinion about it and makes fun of it
maybe right yes yes so like like with
all the news but on the news of this
dad's joke or my face no but what I'm
seeing is real good but the other thing
you gotta worry about too is like like
when was specially you guys you guys are
older when like when you get bullied at
school smash so you guys oh you guys got
bullied at school yeah but what do you
when you guys got bullied at so here's
something right ya know you were always
my favorite I know I didn't beat me know
that you're being really mainly him okay
mostly him okay cool yeah but you know
you know time up but when you get blade
in school you go home you know and there
was like I yeah yeah face that tomorrow
what everyone navigate to it but now
kids are getting bullied it's 24/7 yeah
bullying all online Twitter Instagram
just toxic [ __ ] all 24/7 for those kids
so it's just a different game yeah
that's true they also have that did you
say Twitter bullying too or like
Instagram bullying Graham yeah I think
it's man is I don't know I don't my son
is on snap he's not on Instagram oh
really yeah so I don't know if there's
comments and [ __ ] on it they do that on
there did they do such at bullied Ian
can you hate on people on snap yeah I
mean I had a younger cousin who when she
was still in high school what though
like popular girls would do was post
photos of her onto their snapchat and
then people would start a thread Wow
people are called you know what those
people are called [ __ ] I agree those
are [ __ ] oh that's so
awful man some real content yeah there
oh it's not social time so girls they
say are socially way more aggressive
than boys
oh and so boys are physically aggressive
a punch in the face girls girls for each
other socially they destroy relational
their [ __ ] click yeah they destroy
others in middle school and middle
school girls their anxiety levels have
like my daughter thank God is just into
what she's into she does her thing but I
mean it's really hard for those girls
this yeah I'm sorry how old my son seven
that he's gonna be 17 in two months
doctor here believe I just said the
thick of it he's in the I think of it
yes now he's cool that's why probably
social media yeah no I wasn't bullied I
was so funny though you're fun I was
ready and I and I was so like I was
insecure but my humor got me through it
me too so I was I was blessed in high
school you were athletic really
good-looking so I never had any problems
and I was funny how crazy your hair was
thinning in your face was always old is
that so big that's a fair thing I saw a
baby picture of your face take it back
and usually well usually babies have a
lot of wrinkles and they go he'll grow
into it yeah cuz it's loose skin yeah
you've never grown into it you still
have the wrinkles there yeah it's such a
jerk to me right now I would stop
sunbathing
I don't son that would stop sunbathe I
stay out of the Sun I'm on set all day
that's that's more soundstage in front
of your lights lights lights lights
lights um well this is uh I'm really uh
jealous of your success hey your feets
are casual I can't stop laughing a sad
day hey I'll be honest you're being a
jerk dude
I'm proud of my [ __ ] Tina hey Bo I
love your show it's very funny your cast
is amazing Tim come on Tim is amazing
why don't you come get your amazing I'd
wrap already be this last week got four
more episodes best oh oh we lied to us
you said this is last week no no that is
true he did say that no I said you know
no I was going jump on the bandwagon
I remember that yeah I remember you
saying that and you're like this is my
Latin yeah you lied oh I know Lila
listen no I just I mean just the
[ __ ] yeah
did you see that did you have after this
did you have a favorite movie did you
like Joker more than parasite oh I
haven't seen parasite yeah and you guys
are you guys gonna hate me well I
haven't seen parasite I've noticed I
didn't idea that weird Joaquin is
amazing I can't I can't I know girl I
couldn't it's a heavy move it's too
heavy it never happy I'm sorry man
acting phenomenal Joaquin is amazing huh
will you miss Brian I loved it I loved
it I thought it was a masterpiece I
personally did but that's just me it's
not masterpiece but it's heavy yeah I
watch it on the plane it's Mario I'm
Santa Tony I was like oh this movies
it's too heavy I don't have it dude
movies are like music
there's genre yes you know saying that
that's not my genre yeah I can't there's
some people that love that you have a
favor obby Lee loves to cry yeah
Bobby Lee loves a movie that makes him
cry it's like I cried at [ __ ] Harry
Potter he'll say some dumb [ __ ] like
that I'm like what it's like yeah
they're do you not understand the story
I'm like Oh weird Bobby what the [ __ ]
are you talk he's about using Bobby's
great he's amazing he is he's my friend
like I love by [ __ ] what I'm comic
you're not Bobby's friend unless you
seen his dick eight times that's
probably at least eight times and it's
exactly how you think it is yeah it's
exactly what you think it is what very
straight very straight pubic hair yeah
yeah very straight pubic hair they just
how's that hot girlfriend good for him
dude I know you got a dick blessed you
get it Joe get your dick out and you
[ __ ] huh okay Joe Joe come back Joe oh
did you have the birds of the beasts
talk with your sons no no no I got that
kid tricking up he's working it yeah
yeah stall yeah my dad but I didn't
to my dad no you knew I was I knew yeah
like what's up what's up woman I'll tell
you how I caught him yeah please
are you guys ready for that you install
the camera you're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] was
my camera is a bit smaller than 100 on
your eyelid by the way that's Yoda my
camera guy
shut up he does all my videos doesn't
speak or and look she's not a word
yep he doesn't speak one word of English
but we communicate well Yoda
a lot of hand gestures so yeah that's
how your bowing you look super friendly
very sweaty Yoda yeah you gonna tell
that's Yoda and uh let me get my hand
you know what's crazy Brian is uh we
were out when I introduced some Toyota
and I go he doesn't speak any English
and then Brian walks out to me he looks
at me he goes how does it work what's a
breakout how do you guys communicate
yeah you know Josie you know does it he
kicked the chair he pushed the chair
with his foot he went if I want to I
just go dude you're too rich now what
did he get up he did I can't and back no
Joey you can't and you can't let me lose
your foot no now you're now you're no
don't do it don't man that's so no stay
here Brian come no dude stop gesturing
that's so rude no no no no look no look
no your show world tour sure you don't
have to do this dude you don't have to
do this [ __ ] your beat oh that's the
other thing Josh I'm the best merch in
the game yeah ha hey you're being super
disrespectful Wow no no he's allowed
you're he's not your solo date so he's
not your Godsey a date so to camera he's
not your goddamn robot man oh oh oh
that's so prude you're I'm sorry you
don't have to do this this is America
this is not acceptable the guy's bowing
to him now
why are you doing you're doing a good
thing wow man did you study
yeah I said he cut up I didn't know that
yeah that was clearly a [ __ ] I am I
mean I study and I know the difference
yeah let me see your fist we need a Yoda
oh there's there's a lot of cuts and you
trained I trained secretly yeah Wow I'll
fight man what as long as there's sharp
objects or glass around you're down I'm
gonna use it if I come at you ask a
Chicago diner 15 years ago what happened
so if I come at you I'll throw something
at your [ __ ] face well what's crazy
is your face is made of leather
no so wha no you've been you don't cut
you've been mean about you don't cut
okay I bleed just like everybody else
yes I do I bleed just like everybody
else and I cry and and I you ever tried
tear leather in half you know you can't
impossible that's your face no no that's
your face you're being where's my camera
you're being so rude a enemy is it the
small one yeah it's the big one it's the
big one
no the big one okay man wealth has made
you such a jerk to top it you're mean -
hey little Yoda though I want my own yo
no dude
online you have a brother no you just go
online yeah he has a part and he's not
talking to him so it would be kind of
cool the same room they won't even talk
to each other yeah tell Yoda I want his
brother forever no no God money
please stop doing that to Yoda he's a
human being he's not your [ __ ]
servant hey is his brother name yarmulke
god damn it is 70 them to get water no
no no no Yoda you don't have to do this
you don't have to do stop doing that
with your hand Joe you're [ __ ] so
rude god I'm so jealous I think Joe can
you tell the jerk-off story please ah
[ __ ] man I want my own Yoda yeah calm
Yoshi oh you can have a Yoshi I'm so I'm
so appalled at this [ __ ]
are you offended I'm so offended right
no what's crazy about the whole thing I
have a huge hard-on
I know it turns me on - I don't know why
I oppression turns me on
Yoda speaks English you jerk-off
come on you really didn't see me smoking
yeah I swear I didn't
cuz he was looking at me going I knew
from the Joe this is a very this guy's
from Japan and he's super polite I
didn't know you I truly if you thought
he was a robot hell I believe you speak
English fluently yeah okay but he is
from Japan he looks so friendly though
he's so friendly
Japanese most amazing samurais that he's
the most amazing camera guy in the world
he does all my videos on my Instagram my
job he's one guy
it looks like multi camera it's just him
he's got three cameras he runs back and
forth he gets the shot he comes with
every customer I take him everywhere you
have that DJ - I have a DJ yeah that's
the other thing I tell people all the
time I'm stuck with some other ghetto in
San Antonio with the comics I've seen
the one well one of the many things you
do well a your marketing your merch but
the one time I opened for you in Brea
it's a show man there's a DJ I think
it's well you know like when you went
like really come out let you know stand
up Makenna boy like he's like [ __ ]
it's a show West Palm Beach they're
screaming Britney time I killed by the
way I want you to know that I'm gonna
come out you killed that [ __ ] I told you
man just get on stage I'm coming I'm
coming
do you put heat in front of you yeah you
promised you mean could calm like oh not
good great oh oh you know what I do not
take young really talented people with a
lot of potential I don't take somebody
who and and you guys know you got to put
[ __ ] babies I always do Leo flowers
eight years in the gup-a park rushes yes
Stevie blue eyes crushed all the time
yeah my boy Moloch B who's young yeah
[ __ ] people oh and that was always it
like Rogen though you won't talk about
bringing kick killers like look you
always bring to me I don't care
bees comment I bring beasts yeah but
that's how you Chris D'Elia used to open
for me right uh this kid now Eric
Schwartz kills for me he's crying cause
it's great Eric Oh get like Stan iou's
in front of me and then I look at him go
alright I'm gonna make sure they forget
your name and then I walk out like it
like
alright where's my camera
oh man but that's what you gotta do I
learned that from Cedric the Entertainer
I opened for attentively the story no I
opened for Cedric the Entertainer nod
and this was like this was like 15 years
ago
and I had my son I remember the Indian
Reservation wouldn't let my son on it
sceptic it was like just that a mom and
like just let him in because they were
like strict can't have kids on the
property yeah cuz that a baby it's a
casino and I and I'm just big I had
nowhere to go like oh I got my kid you
know I mean so uh he get he somehow he
gets him to come in lets him in and and
I go up and I do my [ __ ] I do my
Tonight Show set bro I'm doing all those
[ __ ] bangers just bah bah bah like 15
jokes compact into like what we I think
he gave me like 10 minutes yeah I got
them all in there man just bangers
bangers good night ba 3,000 people
they're jumping up I'm walking on stage
in my head I'm like you ain't gonna fall
yeah good luck bro yeah no I'm being
serious you know [ __ ] up [ __ ] and I look
to my left and Cedric's got his goddamn
fedora on matching outfit you know me
and he's bouncing he's looking he's like
that's rump talk about jo koy make me
work for that [ __ ] money tonight
let's go ask and he shook my hand and
walked past me and I'm like oh [ __ ] cuz
I would've never said I would have been
like [ __ ] this show yeah it was done I
swear to god to always be my love always
my philosophy and every time I hear
about a comic who has like some shitty
comic I'm like that guy's [ __ ] doesn't
have any confidence yeah what is it
you're a [ __ ] you're the softball lob
what you don't hear about people have a
shitty comics ropers yeah you do I mean
I mean now you got it you if you don't
and it's not fair to your audience
either like you're gonna charge you
should've give them a good show you got
to show them like one you're the
headliner so like you make sure that
whoever's in front of you
crushes and then you show everybody what
a head Leonard I've always said that 20%
of the audience if 20% of me is saying
the feature should have been the
headliner you're doing your job like
that's a great show
yeah I mean
I remember Mike Young none of them say
that for me I don't 100% you are the
headliner yeah I'm making a point I'll
have someone open like they'll say that
I'll make a plan I know I know but I'm
just saying like for me no they usually
go holy [ __ ] did even was there anybody
else on this like anybody lately forgot
that said I heard the story about Cedric
the Entertainer when they did that the
Kings of Comedy Tour yeah so a Cedric
Steve Harvey by the way back your this
is crazy are we on the same wavelength
right now like I'm not even joking with
you because the Jim Carrey reference I'd
literally just saw that yesterday's a
collage thing and then this Kings of
Comedy you can look at my Netflix queue
I just watched it the other day some
days ago in my line Yoda you had two
days ago we watching he's never seen it
before and and I was just like oh my god
I could not believe Steve was the
[ __ ] host did you but that wasn't
[ __ ] he blew the deal went up and
[ __ ] first it birdie but you know
Bernie Mac at the time he was gonna like
host yeah opener yeah they did one show
and they were like everyone was like oh
[ __ ] yeah you need to be like what do
they do
so DL Hughley wasn't in the originals
there was another guy and when they went
somewhere the guy complained he didn't
have his I forget who it is the people
find out really so they had three limos
and he didn't have his own he looks at
Steve Harvey who organized everything
and he was like yo man where the [ __ ]
my car SEMA excuse me here's where the
[ __ ] my car yes cool story dude they
did that show they kicked him off which
guys I brought in Bernie wait who is it
who I don't know the comic but they but
they kicked because you're hating me but
the first night Bernie goes off tonight
and crush like harder than all of them
they went they all had in the in the
locker room that night we're like so
Bernie's in girl ass from now on and
everyone's like yeah yeah I'm of course
Hedrick TL Harvey awesome on that height
of the the chitlin circuit like like Ron
no one knew who the [ __ ] Bernie was this
guy was doing stuff he was even doing
improv sister was literally doing the
underground circuit yeah so for him to
come out swinging like that it's just
[ __ ] my favorite part of that whole
thing is I like the mini Docs that they
put him in Sweeney Jack and uh and the
one with Bernie when he literally looked
at the camera goes it's my turn
[ __ ] yeah they already got shows
onions show yeah give me a [ __ ] show
man who did not only did he get a show
she cut the movies he got everything
what people forget to is a Bernie at the
time when they got done with Kings a
comment or those other guys are pretty
set but [ __ ] burning here bro Ocean's
eleven well they 1200 Cedric was on Marc
Maron and he goes people what people
don't realize is Bernie
couldn't go anywhere like that's like
Chappelle at what Journal Chappelle is
now learning Mac back then his ticket
what about died they had that disease
that got your lungs P now I'm gonna die
let me yeah you [ __ ] did we go to break
no Keep Calm no you like you know kind
of connect like yeah yeah yeah we're
actually it's actually probably better a
fighter in the koi that's right
but yeah a fighter in the koi well
there's a K already there can you record
that can you record that I want this
documented there's already a K so the
fighter in the koi kind of flows so do
your set bro which ones my camera right
which one's the camera
yeah but they said Bernie Mac meant
after that just unbelievable couldn't go
anywhere they he was basically what
Chappelle is now back then because
Cedric was saying like people forget
like he had a set that he had a 7-minute
set the viewed for TV before he got on
and Cedric sets the the best stand up
he's ever heard in his life
I said no like it he would do it all
over and nobody want to follow no [ __ ]
just such a monster monster harvey was
the brains behind all this
oh yeah it showed he's a hospital dude
I'll turn you though that opening set I
was like what in the [ __ ] no I remember
looking at Yoda I go Yoda I go D Elle's
gotta follow that yeah he's gotta follow
that I saw DL Hughley at one of my
favorite restaurants yes at my himself
oh that's a cool pad yeah well I got I
finally got to do DL show and I just I
paid homage the man and I and I told him
how much more
I saved up just to watch him perform at
the Aladdin theater yeah when I was
living in Vegas of how I was addicted to
comicview and how it was my dream to be
on that show Wow and uh and the way I
got comic for you was crazy
I was working at the dolphin habitat and
I found out that comic Vee was actually
in Vegas doing a show and I asked my
manager if I can get off and I and I
literally went home put my suit on and I
had a fake that's me right there and had
a fake no that's Apollo the bats come
with you and then put that suit that
berry suit right there is the one I put
on she and I went to the event where
where comicview was went to the security
guard when as the security guard ever
helped anybody and I go hey I'm a comic
and I just want to try and get up is
there any way I can talk to the promoter
and he went got the promote now what a
good dude yeah so he went got the
promoter her name is Yvette Anderson big
shout-out to bopi and Yvette and her
since she came to the door she goes we
already got our show set you know I wish
I would have known about you but the
next time we come back to Vegas we'll
put you on right Wow so I was like oh
all right it's all good there was a huge
line to get in I was talking about how I
got comic view and um and there was a
huge line to get in and she looked at me
she goes do you still want to watch the
show I'll [ __ ] ya you gotta remember
this is like 1995 or some [ __ ] I can't
remember what he says yeah that's me and
then uh and then she let me in right and
it's packed it's packed and all the
comics are late duh right and she looked
at and everyone in the crowds going
crazy like the pissed because they're
like it's 45 minutes later like it's
supposed to start at 8:00 it's like
almost 9:00 and then uh and she goes you
want to go up and I remember she had
this this big-ass camera was a camera a
Canon gl it was maroon and white it was
like I knew what that cameras cuz I
always wanted it was like a five
thousand dollar camera I always wanted I
Cameron I go I go if I go can you please
record it with that camera because I
wanted to use it as tape tape yeah and
she goes oh yeah got it she set it up
for me and I went up I still have the
video and and I went up [ __ ] I get a
standing O right and uh and then bopi
and her on the side of the stage and
bopi goes we're gonna put your own comic
feet and that's literally how I got I
was working about the dolphin habitat
and I remember going to work the next
day often habitat I was really at the
dolphin habitat the tour guide as in
dolphins yeah how was the tour guide and
one of the tour guides goes comicview is
here because I was such a comic VPI was
such a deal hugely fan and Cedric fan
and uh I was like what
and I literally asked my manager if I
can go home and I literally walked up to
the door with a fake resume and I handed
it to the security guard and that's how
I got on because I feel like you're
getting closer to what you want like it
yeah I was doing it six years yeah
maybe six years and you're doing you're
doing might know and in Vegas didn't
have comedy clothes no you're good my
was doing literally like copy however
you can I know the big club back then
was a big movie theater women's ledger
grind when yeah it's like back then
before you could even get audience no
you don't understand it was such a grind
like just it was just so hard waiting
there is no comical all the comedy clubs
were closing across the country remember
the comic view was closed I mean uh
Comedy Central was basically it was a
good thing because everyone got to see
get exposure for comics but it was a bad
thing because known was going to the
comedy clubs anywhere because now
they're watching stand-up there'd be 12
people in the original it was nobody the
main room is always empty yeah what does
the name mean nobody was ever and the
original room and have twelve people in
it yeah we'd be doing it was always
subdued I you know what was on my resume
that when I handed it to this to the
promoter I said I opened for Bruce baby
man baby man bomb do you know him Bruce
bomb remember him and Vic Dunlop those
are my bro damn and she let me in and
literally I got comic view and they flew
me out two weeks later I was on comic
view
and where was comic of you filmed that
it was in the UH at the Commerce Casino
I think like somewhere here in LA that's
Bruce baby man bomb and how did your
sect on topic for you I got a standing
oh I got you uh you worked at the
dolphin habitat do you have secret
knowledge of dolphins I I know I know
that hot I know a lot here's what I uh
this is this is what I used to do
there's twelve of them in that habitat
well I don't know how many there are now
and you know I take him underneath right
and there's a bunch of windows and then
pee
ask questions but you have to name them
so I go that's that scooter I would name
the real names by the way that scooter
that's banjo know them you knew them
Alysha whatever and then and then at the
end of my tour they go which ones Alicia
and I was just pointed any gray one
because I didn't [ __ ] another now it's
no now were they were they unhappy or
you couldn't tell okay so they told us
that the rake marks are natural behavior
that they always play fight and bite
each other on the tail
she's [ __ ] dolphins look like they
were knife fights 24/7 they're great
here we're [ __ ] locking rake marks
all over the body and just do ratchet
each other each other they would just
fight all the time
it wasn't until I you know got older and
started watching about mammals and
watching it watching you know about
dolphins and well that these are family
members that are stripped from their
families and brought to another family
and put into a house what's just some
dudes so there's a dude and a chick um
either just looking at each other
swimming and like live and yeah live but
by the way they're mammals
so they hate each other yes one still
looking for their dolphins were against
each other they wore that pods worgen
yeah they're dudes oh [ __ ] each other
man
no gay yeah hey Jay they were so
aggressive in that pool and you would
always have to say oh they always play
fight they weren't play fight and that's
they hated each other it's just like you
know I mean it's like it's not a natural
pop well it's like an often in Mall of
America [ __ ] it's idols I'm so against
it now that I learned I've never thought
about it until black so of course you're
in them but then you see it and you hear
them crying L somebody say yeah it's sad
man it's really really sad flipper and
I've got 15 minutes kids before I have
to go back to act and I thought we'd do
some current events let's do it well
it's not doing the reeds by myself dude
don't quit them again I'm sorry before
you guys do this
can I ask Brian a serious question and
don't get it don't get mad at me don't
be shitty um well have I been yes very
much so
worst of all time now now be nice what
we can ask I'm just gonna ask you okay
have you memorized your line the one
line Joe that's a shitty you're being
you're being a dick and your fake
sucking that right now what oh man there
be so means I got though don't be that
way
I want one so bad oh you get there cheap
I want my share cheap dolphin ah let me
kind of guy I want my own Yoshi know his
name that's not his real [ __ ] name
it is Yoda yes Yoda dude let me speak
let me speak to him in his own tell me
Joe oh that's ow oh but you can do it
because you have these two I speak some
John oh my this shirt man
because the Korean that's Korean way
more Korean no that is that is that is
Japanese watch acog II do
Shiro Bavaro really yeah that's a swear
very racist
what is that oh I hate oh that's all
that's a swear word right yeah I know
what up what about please don't stop how
about you
I am old here is saying I'll I'll
translate go [ __ ] I thought that I was
here dude say just be Japanese and I'll
do the voiceover how you did I am comedy
you carry my face she don't eight lines
equals you're kidding 90 years old it's
like when you get a agent tattoo you
think it means like life and I mean
[ __ ] dolphin did yeah I thought I was
I heard that in a samurai movie and so
I've been doing that Oh Lord Jesus
I've read a lot of Japanese literature
you'll have you know I've read a lot of
Japanese I read a lot of Japanese
authors and I'm like these [ __ ] -
this is racist
I'll do I read a bunch of Japanese book
I read offf Yukio Mishima spokes red
bananas boxer what the [ __ ] is this
banana
I went through Nana's mom I went with
Jeff give us you have this good event
let's go let's save more than okay this
was submitted by hey soos Duran there's
a clip of a stripper falling down from a
15-foot Pole that went violet I'm going
to show you guys have you seen this oh
she's bad fractured her jaw fractured
and broke teeth she broke a couple of
teeth I love her dad starting to have
learned because her jaw was [ __ ] up
love her well done sweaty feet she fell
correct it was a 15-foot Pole I would
have a shoe rub it with a 20-foot pole
who does that how did you do it was it
just how I think she just did something
wrong with in her routine and then she
fell uh you know a good point I think
there was something very wrong with that
root area yeah yeah yeah they're very
wrong a 15-foot Pole in a strip club
first of all no disrespect she's a
badass okay I love her I would
definitely odd bless her god bless you
I'm glad she's healthy when you're
looking at [ __ ] popping uh it you don't
see it from 15 feet up so let's just
bring the pulse down look at her right
good think she didn't fall on that girl
below yeah whoa break that net why
should grow
she came hard dude and stood on her for
days she's a badass okay the show must
go on is what I always said you 100%
show must go 100% down dude what else
you got what's crazy she made no tips on
that one to know what threw money no I
would [ __ ] rain that night I went it she
did break character she did break no she
didn't break characters my back she got
working not fast enough
that's true not playing she was
concussed though oh but that her teeth
yeah this might be my boater so I said
okay so there have been a bunch of
videos going around where people are
doing this broom challenge some
he said it was rumored that nASA
released a statement saying that on a
specific day any broom that you would
try to stand up straight would stay
because of like the earth is it's a tail
the rotation is in a very specific place
where grooms will stand up straight
which is was clearly [ __ ] but then
these videos end up going viral and now
people are just crazy
so NASA say today is the day the only
day that your brain can stand up on his
own and watch this oh my god yo no
streets nothing no that's correct that's
crazy well the earth is flat why it's
Jeff how do you know that uh Triple E
and uh Eddie Bravo
it's stroke duh so I believe it how are
these people do now is just just trying
to find the balancing point that's it
but this went viral and then a bunch of
people said that it didn't work on their
brooms cuz they had the little Asian
ones like it doesn't you know what I
mean we're passion sighs you've been
ordering him around you've been calling
him Yoshi no no I want least I'm the
only one who speaks the language here I
can ask what Nana's banana what that one
was pretty great and great writer great
nation I don't remember his name though
you know I read a lot of care I'm gonna
go out on a limb and say his name is not
bananas yeah I've also been to knee fall
sorry
well it doesn't it did this doesn't
validate what you did to my friend Yoda
over there yeah that's yo de when you
pretend that's just not a Japanese ice
do you want to hear his real name you
want two years earlier let's see you can
say your real name the right way with
the perfect it's Steve you [ __ ]
racist a is Yoda is his [ __ ] nickname
cuz he's a Star Wars fanatic alright god
Pan Steve yeah it's short for stevedore
all day you're not browsing you're not
smelling move as well Steve I'm glad
we're seeing your true color yeah man no
sorry Steve
holy [ __ ] light the cross on fire all
right so the rocks eldest daughter has
officially signed on to WWE and this
makes her officially the first person to
be in the fourth generation of like
wrestling family really the great
grandfather yeah but there's so many
wrestling families hearts all of them
Mads are the main roads flare hey the
Otters a champ
the she's the fourth one though I think
there have been a whole wide scores it
okay I'm gonna season tomorrow I'm
stupid I'm slow I'm slow that's dope
have you ever seen her mom have you seen
have you seen rocks uh x5 tomorrow nope
nope don't play takes aunt appearances
as the rock Oh Jack are you saying this
really natural she's jacked jack city
has uh the rock always been good-looking
son of a [ __ ] yes yes the guy's 50 what
now no 47
no he can't be younger than this younger
he's 50 right I think you know he looks
phenomenal man like phenomenal there she
is oh my lord that's his ex oh and
that's with my boy Phil Heath blood does
X do I okay that's how sorry I'm sorry
that's impressive huh oh is that guy
who's that guy Phil Heath used to be mr.
Olympia seven oh that's him Denver he's
from Seattle originally stop yeah I
played at you you dumb breakdown really
played a deep sorry either way he's from
Seattle but yeah that's the Rock's
ex-wife damn she's young she manages him
now to manages the rock yeah oh you know
what else she buries it she end up being
his manager yeah no doubt so they're
still best friends
yeah pretty close Barry right you know
else really knowing that great you know
manages
the zero it's alright man dude not a
good yours not a good way to get them on
the show lock is not a good way you're
saying the rocks not natural it's good
looking good looking rid of them I don't
think the rock I think the rock is
natural all the way one other section
whatever yet all right let's move on to
you know who's on roids
oh no I'm not don't nod to me like that
don't spread rumors about me just
because I'm naturally muscular leather
face or no face
do you have a picture of the face gosh I
could pull it up look at pull up leather
face and tell me this is it Bryan Callen
just like waking up in the morning
that's upright Callen no that's upright
early in the morning no no before you
put on kind of moisturizer oh that's so
bright there I bought that mask before
on Halloween it's not the Bryan Callen
that's called the Bryan Callen right
there there's that new doctor is it
Netflix the the mr. rinks stealing
[ __ ] jokes and I talked about doing a
TV show so old that I'm sell shirts that
say rah rah rah rah rah rah rah
hey you bro you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm buying
that though this Halloween hey Bryan
Callen I gotta go I love that because
they will kill me if I'm late again you
do the reeds on your own or I can come
in tomorrow do something I'll come in
tomorrow do drast a man yeah just do it
real quick let's just knock them out
together the three of us okay let's go
we got do we have any more to we I do up
kita yeah and uh if you guys would do
honored as well look I'll be three hey
if you guys want the best supplements on
planet Earth and you want to look like
Jo koy and not me you get on on it you
take on it
I love
all right yeah that's why I'm on it yeah
you're all mine I'm honored chance on it
shins on it on a.com slash know what I
love about shin ever since he's been on
it yeah you can see his chin that's
exactly that's no [ __ ] and it's draw
very chiseled look at that shredded dude
the protein powder is sweetened by
monkford I don't know if you know that
doesn't spike your insulin mmm yeah you
knew that I need that yeah don't let the
Alpha brain be alpha brain you want a
clear [ __ ] brain you want to increase
your memory and focus you won't be good
will be ill I'm okay comedy yes Mountain
brain they got an instant instant mix it
in your drink and drink it yeah look it
smarter auto cops last Friday 10% off
yeah you want a [ __ ] well they got stuff
for that too okay I don't know man I
want to be on it on a dot cos Spyder
love it represent off you know I be the
one thing health experts dieticians
athletes and top performers agree on is
that your perfect diet doesn't exist
dude it doesn't exist man cuz you need
you need some help you need some help
yeah so why don't you shut your yapper
and swallow athletic greens ultimate
daily all-in-one health drink 75
vitamins minerals I thought there was
only four and they're they're free
sourced ingredients you bastards
comprehensive nutrition without the need
from multiple pills powders or complex
routines it's a complete supplement for
a better you dude here's the thing its
power to form you put it in water I was
trying to shovel spinach down my throat
doesn't work don't need to do that
anymore
it's got probiotics and prebiotics too
and fiber all the fiber you mean I
didn't know there was such thing as a
prebiotic until on it now you know this
is basically like swallowing twelve
servings of fruit and vegetables alright
start each day the right way with some
athletic greens that's not compromising
ingredients and sourcing it's gluten
free dairy free Kate keto paleo vegan
friendly vegan friendly and contains no
harmful chemicals no pesticides no GMOs
and it's used by top performers
entrepreneurs athletes and Olympians yes
will they're taking steps towards a
healthier lifestyle or you're an athlete
push up for better performance
athletic greens gives you the nutrients
you need for a body to thrive why not
just try it jump on over to
letti greens.com slash fighter and claim
the special offer today a free table
with 20 servings of all-natural New
Zealand source humpf st. grass-fed whey
protein with your first purchase
that's your micronutrients and macros
covered all in one I guess athletic come
on
athletic greens calm / fighter but I
will say this that I used to take
athletic greens a lot so that's my this
product and I believe in good pitch
athletic greens calm / fighter athletic
greens the official sponsor of the
fighter in the koi I like it don't like
that it's got actually awesome what is
this now dude this is Kyoto bars dude oh
yeah
he eats bars that's right man key bars
are keto friendly seriously do delicious
might be the best bars I've ever put in
my fat mouth you know me I stay thick
dude yeah but I'm trying to be on this
ketogenic diet so I need tasty stuff
thank God for ki eats bars with absolute
no sugar they're sweetened with FDA
approved keto sugar replacements um
they're entirely plant-based so you can
use them you're clean keto do clean
alright we love the ones they sent this
my favorites probably the chocolate chip
cookie dough like these I can't wait
can't wait we can't involve watch you
how about you guys know he eats dot-com
fighters and put all yeah yeah and then
lick your I use my key to go to she eats
calm / fighter try
she eats bars for free that's right
three free bars with free shipping
that's key eats dot-com / fighter Joe
quiet love you I love you more you're
the best
Thank You crowd of all your success all
[ __ ] aside you one of my favorite
people in the world thank you for doing
the fighter the best man come see me at
the West Palm Beach improv this weekend
Friday Saturday Sunday
jo koy doesn't need any commercial
provisional need any thousand [ __ ]
ticket - yes I'm in Ontario there 20
tickets left for all shows then Thursday
Friday Saturday Ontario improv next week
Vancouver that [ __ ] almost sold out to
Vogue Theater Just for Laughs comedy
festival Vancouver and I closed the
month in Tacoma Washington favorite 27th
to 29th get your tickets now theater run
coming up Atlanta New Orleans do
Troy Toronto Minneapolis get your tasty
become I added a show Oh show where Kent
Washington oh wow the adil Washington
added another Seattle don't get mad but
I added an arena show yeah I'm happy
cake it's hopefully somewhere I mean I
go to tea pack a calm and you can get
them off my website further if you come
to the west palm beach in Maui get you
half ticket price tickets to Joe quick
this is the fighter in the koi we're out